mais les jours sur le champ qu'est ce
qu'on va faire d'extraordinaire
quand on va les sens
ours quel bonheur de te retrouver quel
bonheur sans cesse renouvelée parce que
tu es un peu le parrain de cette
émission il faut le dire écoute ça fait
plusieurs fois que je viens à chaque
fois un vrai plaisir ton album précédent
cette époque ce qui était un succès qui
a cartonné là tu reviens avec ton single
donc qui s'appelle cinquième saison la
cinquième saison alors vive à le dire
c'était les quatre saisons toi tu t'es
dit je vais pousser un peu plus loin
cinquième saison c'est quoi mais c'est
justement puisque l'on connaît par coeur
ce cycle perpétuel
automne hiver printemps été automne
hiver printemps était il fallait un
moment qu'on casse un peu ça en tout cas
on attend tous cet air frais ce nouvel
erp et on attend tous un air nouveau que
ce soit dans nos vies dans notre couple
dans notre travail chacun se
l'approprient comme il veut mais voilà
c'est ça la cinquième saison c'est ce
renouveau on attend la cinquième saison
elle est vraiment magnifique et que
cette chanson c'est une chanson qui est
empreinte de mélancolie j'ai
l'impression que pour toi poésie rime
souvent avec mélancolie quand même
mélancolie à une profondeur qui fait les
meilleures chansons que le les morceaux
plus pop
dont tu es capable aussi oui oui c'est
vrai mais ouais je suis je suis capable
et en même temps on en a besoin dans le
chemin d'un an holmes après avoir écrit
trois chansons un petit peu trop sombre
et un peu enfin on a peur d'embêter les
gens et de plomber les gens mais non
mais tu ne nous embêtent jamais non mais
on a peur de ça donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut du mitsouko un peu de fantaisie un
peu on va semis de souquet balade semi
dessous et on va celui de souk est super
mais dans cette chanson aussi tu évoques
une certaine forme de routine dans la
cinquième saison parce que c'est pour
lutter contre la routine que tu allais
enregistré à bruxelles j'avais besoin
d'aller voir ailleurs forcément il s'est
aussi passé quelque chose de très
important il ya eu un gros projet sait
que j'ai eu un enfant ah ça c'est le
projet d'une vie ou projet d'une vie
alors il fallait un moment que je parte
un peu de ce quotidien très prenant et
pour écrire des chansons alors je
voulais pas aller à la campagne ou aller
au bord de la mer comme j'ai l'habitude
de faire j'avais de peur un peu de
m'endormir je voulais aller sentir une
autre ville j'avais besoin d'une ville
de l'urgence d'une ville et il ya une
ville qui m'a toujours attiré j'y
passais jamais plus de trois jours et là
j'ai voulu me poser plus longtemps c'est
bruxelles alors tu le sais la thématique
qu'on va vous imposez à vous les
artistes dans cette émission c'est la
résistance les artistes est en
résistance qu'est ce que c'est pour toi
être un artiste en résistance en ce
moment mais pour moi je me suis dit
tiens qu'est-ce que je peux faire moi je
vais je vais quand je vais créer je vais
composer on a que ça à faire puisqu'on
veut pas aller sur les routes on peut
parler sur les scènes alors
voilà on a de la chance quand même de
pouvoir continuer à faire notre métier
c'est celui d'écrire des chansons donc
même si mon album n'est pas sorti je
suis déjà en train d'écrire des
nouvelles chansons et ça c'est ma
résistance à moi une surtout une manière
de ne pas me laisser plombé par ce
climat qui peut moralement
vous entamez
voilà on continue à placer les dates et
à répéter même si parfois si on a
l'impression de se répéter pour rire
mais on répète je fais semblant d'avoir
des débuts publics devant moi et je mets
devant un miroir
et alors ce soir tu vas fondre ton de
l'univers avec l'univers d'une autre
artiste une grande artiste enzo enzo
vous avez commencé à vous rencontrer à
voir si ça peut coller artistiquement
c'est chaque est super dans renversants
ce que c'est vraiment la
troisième fois que j'ai fait cette
émission c'est ça c'est la rencontre que
vous provoquez entre des artistes on est
ravis ion on va voir on essaie de mettre
au point
une chanson ou deux chansons on va voir
autour du thème que vous nous avez
imposé la résistance
on va peut-être faire un petit mashup de
deux chansons en voilà où je vous verrai
ce soir merci ours merci à toi tu revoir
cet endroit chaque année l'état le
pouvoir tout là bas
il sape de 5 à l'égout tour et les
carreaux
[Musique]